Şimdi size bir soru soracağım İz bırak
meselesi var ya size bir soru soracağım
onun cevabını konuşmanın sonunda
birlikte bakacağız
farz edin 10.000 yıl sonra dayız
Ankara diye bir şehir kalmamış işte
toprakla Kaplamış her tarafı daha önce
başka şehirlerde olduğu gibi değil mi
Mesela Efes bir liman şehri Halbuki
20-25 km içeride coğrafya
diyelim 10.000 yıl sonranın birileri
bilim insanları arkeolojik kazı yapmaya
karar veriyorlar Ankara'da
ne bulacaklar
sorun bu bunu burada tutuyorum şimdi
şu gördüğünüz harita biliyorsunuz değil
mi dünya haritası
hala kullanıyoruz bunu bu harita marka
Tor projeksiyonu diye biliniyor
o çizmiş
notuma bakıyorum
1568'de Hala kullanıyoruz
dünyayı temsil ediyor mu
Bence etmiyor yani bakıyoruz Grönland
neredeyse Avrupa kıtasından zaten büyük
görünüyor da hani Afrika kadar filan
o zaman yapılmış marka topu projeksiyonu
geliyor ve kürenin etrafına bir kağıt
sarmış işte bir silindir olmuş o onu
açmış bu çıkmış
bu
Robinson projeksiyonu
bakın burada çok daha oranlı şeyler
Arthur Robinson diye bir bilim insanı
bunu
1960 3'te yapmaya başlamış 74'te
bitirmiş
ne kadar farklı değil mi
fakat hala eksik bu günün dünyasını ve
önümüzdeki birkaç Hatta 10 yılın
dünyasını anlatmakta yetersiz
çünkü; dünyanın çok büyük bir kısmını
kapsayan
yani neredeyse yarısını yüz ölçümünün
kapsayan Pasifik Okyanusu
İkisinde de kenarda bir takım mavilikler
dünya ticaretinin yüzde yetmişi
Muhtemelen ileriki haritalarda bu
projeksiyon kullanılmaz Bu da yani bu
zaten Eskide de bu da kullanılmaz
yansıtmıyor yani ve siyaseti ne
coğrafyayı doğru yansıtıyor
her kayıyor
Şimdi bunu nasıl çizdi İnsanoğlu
Robinson projeksiyonu nasıl ortaya çıktı
uzay çalışmalarını Dışarıdan bakınca
anlaşıldı ki öyle değil yani o kadar
büyük değil yani Bu görüldü bu çıktı
ortaya Peki uzay çalışmalarına nasıl
başladı nereden başlar
şimdi o yüzden biraz birazcık geriye
gideceğiz
ha bakayım ne kadara 1800'lere gideceğiz
1800'lerin başında yanoş mor yaydı
hoş boyu yani İz bırak diyoruz ya çok iz
bıraktı şimdi söyleyeceğim ama
bilmiyoruz değil mi
yanlış gol yi
13 yaşında başlamış şeyi Matematik
Öğrenme babasının tavsiyesiyle ısrarıyla
öğrenmeye başlamış ve
kafaya takmış bu öklid'in 5 tane teorisi
var biliyorsunuz şimdi teori diyoruz ama
o zaman teori değil beşincisi aksiyon
deniyor daha kanıtlanmamış asırlar
boyunca Öklid biliyorsunuz yani milattan
önce işte 330'da doğmuş
270'lerde ölmüş iskenderiyeli
Grek matematikçi Daha doğrusu geometriyi
icat eden kişi olarak biliniyor
o şeyleri de hepsini tek tek saymayayım
ama işte iki noktayı birleştiren en kısa
yol düz bir çizgidir diyor mesela değil
mi Bir tane çizgiyi İki tarafa doğru
sonsuza kadar uzatabilirsiniz filan
diyor bunların beşincisi o zamana kadar
kanıtlanamıyor
diyor ki Bir üçgenin iç açılar toplamı
180 derecedir Bugün bir saniye ilkokulda
öğrendiğimiz şeyler değil mi o zaman
daha kanıtlanamıyor yani var o biliniyor
da kanıtlanamıyor
bu beşinci aksiyon o zaman bunu başka
türlü yaptığında da birlikte yani
birbirini kesmeyen çizgiler sonsuza dek
paralel olarak uzanabilir bunu
kanıtlamaya çalışıyor bütün
matematikçiler o zamana kadar yani
ölülerden gausa aklınıza kim geldiyse ve
beceremiyorlar bu boyayı diyor ki Ya ben
bunu şey yapamıyorum diyor yani mevcut
referanslarla mevcut
bunu çözemiyorum diyor mevcut bilgiler
nedir şimdi biraz geriye dönelim öklit
geometriyi bulan kişi dedik ya Öklid
düzlemi tarif ediyor düzlem Yani tek
boyutlu Dünya 2 boyutlu ya çıktığımız
zaman biz dekarta gidiyoruz yöne kart
yöne kart bize iki boyuttan yani
düzlemden uzaya çıkmayı şey yapıyor x y
z koordinatları değil mi biliyoruz
partezleyen geometri deniyor bunun
la Tabi o zaman
tersine çevireyim Hani az önce tarihçi
hocamızla söyledi ya marks'tan falan
bahsetti marks'ın 11 Teoremi var yani
Soyer bak üzerinde tezler de 11 diyor ki
Şimdiye kadar filozoflar dünyayı
tanımlamakla uğraştı Biz değiştireceğiz
dersine çeviriyor Şimdi burada da bu
diyor ki ben bir tersine çevireyim
bakayım diyor yani iki tane çizgi
birbirine paralel çizgi sonsuzda kesişir
bunu kanıtlayayım sonra onu bir
invertediliyor yani terse şimdi
okullarımızda okutuyoruz Ortadoğu Teknik
Üniversitesi'nde Ben de orada öğrendim
yani matris Bir de inverter var değil mi
yani tersine çeviriyoruz
yapayım diyor
bakıyor ki kartezyen koordinatlarla bu
olmuyor Ben başka bir şey yapayım diyor
[Müzik]
bunu yaparken aynı yıllarda aynı
yıllarda bir Rus matematikçi de aynı
çizgiyi izliyor O da kafaya takmış bu
beşinci aksiyonu Çünkü o zaman Hocalar
ders veriyorlar Bunlar mesela İkisi de
Gaus ekolünden geliyor ya utanıyorsunuz
tanıyayım
yani tanımıyorsanız da tanıyın Yani
ortada o teknik üniversitesi'ndeyiz
Allah aşkına yani ondan sonra
oradan geliyorlar O da bir tersine
çeviriyor aynı şekilde o da aynı
yıllarda Bakın aynı yıllarda
O da hiperbaroid ekseni alıyor kendisine
referans olarak kartezyeni bırakıyor
artık kartezyen akıl son derece statik
bir akıldır her şeyi anlatmamıza yeter x
y z ama uzayı tanımlayamıyor uzayı
tanımlayan ve cismi tanımlıyor uzayı
tanımlayamıyor Şimdi burada Yola çıkıyor
o da o da aynı şeyi buluyor İkisi de ne
oluyor biliyor musunuz
İkisi de üniversitelerinden atılıyorlar
böyle saçmalık böyle Zırva olmaz diye
fakirlik içinde ölüyorlar
ikisi de
sonra
yıllar yılları kovalıyor
Birinci Dünya Savaşı İkinci Dünya Savaşı
Uzay Yarışı
yani uzaya çıkılacak artık uzaya nasıl
çıkılıyor şimdi İkinci Dünya Savaşı
bitince Almanlar uzay çalışmalarında çok
ileri Alman yani Nazi döneminin
mühendisleri uzay mühendisleri roket
mühendisleri bir kısmı Amerika'ya
gidiyor bir kısmı Sovyetler birliğine
giriyor
Aslında her ikisini de yani Hem Apollo
programını hem soyunus programının
kullandığı roketler aynı roketlerdir R2
roketi bir işte
V5 dedi Öbürü başka bir şey dedi ama
aynı hakikaten tuhaftır Yani aynı Nazi
bilim adamlarının şeyini attığı
tohumlarını attığı roketler
şimdi ikisi de bunları çalışmaya
başlıyorlar fakat
yerleştiremiyorlar yukarıya neden
baştan şey yapalım şimdi ökli ne diyordu
iki noktayı birleştiren en kısa yol düz
bir çizgidir diyordu değil mi Doğru mu
bu
kağıt üzerinde doğru Ankara ile
İstanbul'u birleştiren en kısa yol düz
bir çizgi midir Hayır küre üstünde bir
yaydır değil mi Dünya yuvarlak çünkü
Dünya yuvarlak ama
Biz yuvarlak olarak yukarıya attığımız
da bir de güneşin etrafında dönüyor
değil mi çift kademeli bir dinamizm var
ortada yani ikinci dereceden bir dinamik
denklem var hiperbol
tamam mı
şeyde O zaman artık adı leningrad olmuş
olan sen Petersburg
kütüphanesinde birisi buluyor bunu
lobachevski'nin çalışmalarını buluyor
diyor ki ya Bir Delinin biri bunu böyle
yapmış üniversiteden de atmışlar Bir de
şuna bakalım filan diyor bakıyorlar
işte Sovyetler Birliği'nin uzay
yarışında bir adım öne geçmesi ilk şeyde
bu hiperbolik
referansları Yani kartezyeni bırakıp
kartezyen aklı bırakıp hiperbolitakla
dinamit akla geçtikleri anda şak diye
uyduyu
noktacık demek Rusça oraya
yerleştiriyorlar orada duruyor artık
uzay şeyi başlıyor Amerikalılar onun
onlardan çalıyor Sovyetler
amerikalılardan çok daha büyük bir şey
çaldılar atom atom bombasını çaldılar
nasıl oldu o da yine Nazi almanyasında
yetişen bir atom fizikçisi Klaus
bu kişi kaçıyor daha şeylerden yani
ilk başlarında savaşın İngiltere'den
iltica alıyor İngiltere'de o sırada Tube
var Bunlar Kanada İngiliz yani Kanadalı
İngiltereli ve Amerikan bilim adamları
zaten çalışıyorlar Bir Hani atomu nasıl
parçalarız da öldürürüz insanları o
şekilde diye o zaten çalışıyorlar
bir noktadan sonra artık İngiltere'ye
yönelik saldırılar arttıkça Nazi
saldırıları Bunlar Amerika'ya
yerleşiyorlar Amerika'da meşhur Los Anam
olsun üstü burada fizik çalışmaları işte
atom parçalama çalışmaları
patlatıyorlar işi işte
Japonya'ya atılıyor bomba İkinci Dünya
Savaşı bitiyor Fakat daha ki ya bir
devletin bunun elinde olması büyük bir
tehlikedir dünya egemenliğine yol açar
bunu
karşı tarafa da sızdıralım diyor kendisi
zaten bir komünist
Tamam bir yolunu buluyorlar o sırada
İngiltere'nin
Washington büyükelçiliğinde bir şey var
2 numara müsteşar görevli Donald McQueen
diye bir kişi var bu aynı zamanda
İngiliz gizli servisi Emay 8 Onun bir
ajanı ama Diplomat aynı zamanda Ondan
sonra Fakat
şeyi yönetiyor bir yandan da hani
istihbarat çalışmalarını da yönetiyor
Fakat aslında donald'liğin yani İngiliz
çalışıyor olmasından rağmen aslında bir
kgb casusu Bir Köstebek Canberk diye bir
şey var yani
Üniversitesinde
1930'larda örgütlenmiş bir komünist
casusluk şebekesi var onun üyesi
başlarında kim fil diye bir adam var
Türkiye'de de çok çalışmış
ondan sonra
yani ayrıntılarına girmiyorum meraklısı
için entrikalar kitabı ve meraklısı için
casuslar kitabı diye reklam bu kadarını
yapmış olayım yani meraklılara baksın
Orada da var bütün ayrıntıları
Bu bir yandan aldığı bütün bilgileri
şeye aktarıyor Yani hem merkezine
Londra'ya aktarıyor hem de gerçek
merkezi olan Moskova'ya aktarıyor
köstebek adı üstünde ondan sonra bunun
üzerinden Hani Class bilgileri
sızdırıyor ve Aslında Sovyetler
Birliğinde de var atom bombası
çalışmaları Ama kısa yoldan Hani
hızlandırılmış oluyor
Clause ne yapıyor biliyor musunuz
gidiyor Kendini ele veriyor Ben yaptım
arkadaşlar atıyorlar içeri
çıkıyor 59 yılında
doğrudan doğal manyaya gidiyor Doğu
Alman vatandaşı oluyor Oradaki
çalışmalara Katılıyor mesela Çin'e atom
bombası sırlarını verende yine kılavuzu
gidiyor tamam böyle bir şey şimdi
geleceğiz bu haritalara geleceğiz yine
diyeceğim şu
Hani bu iz bırakma meselesine geliyoruz
ya
bütün bu şeyler hani uzay çalışmaları
atom çalışmaları vesaireler tepeye
çıktık görmeye başladık yarın bir gün
hiperboloit koordinatlar yetmeyecek bize
başka şeyler gerekecek başka şeyler
gerekecek onların peşinden gideceğiz
sonra şu şey meselesi var ya oraya
değinmesem olmaz hani İkisi de hemen
hemen aynı zamanda bir Macar bir Rus
matematikçi aynı şeyi buluyorlar Nasıl
oluyor bu birbirlerinden çalma falan yok
o zaman hani Google'a gir bak falan diye
bir şeyimiz yok yani Ne oldu ama bu
aslında
ta ne zaman size söyleyeyim Çok önceleri
1600'lerde 1675 yılında
aynı ay içinde
integral ve diferansiyel hesap
canımızı okuyan dersler vardır ya onlar
onları aynı ay içinde
Newton
ve good friendness Almanya'da buluyorlar
Hatta o zaman büyük bir kavga çıkıyor
önce sen buldun Ben buldum falan diye
Halbuki
ikisi ayrı noktalardan gelip aynı şeyi
buluyorlar Yani çok da tuhaftır yani
İkisi de
bilim tarihinin en önemli insanları şey
hani fizik kurallarını matematik
kurallarını koyan insanlar ama ikisi de
aslında İlahiyatçı yani İkisi de bunu
yaparken
bir tanesi diyor ki Newton Newton diyor
ki küçücük parçacıklardan bir bütün
Vahdet oluşur
diyorlarlık diyor Aslında küçücük
parçacıkların toplamıdır diyor ikisi
de aynı birine diferansiyel hesaplıyoruz
Öteki de şu integral hesabı var ya
integral işareti onunla yapıyor bunu
bütünleştiriyor
Nasıl oluyor bu ya binlerce yıllık
çalışmanın ürünü patlıyor birikiyor
birikiyor sıçrıyor Ne bileyim ne siyaset
şeyle ilerlemiyor böyle düz parabolik
çizgilerle ilerlemiyor onlara böyle
yakından baktığınız zaman
inişler kırılmalar çıkışlar inişler
kırılmalar çıkışlar öyle bir şey
göreceksiniz öyle bir şey göreceksiniz
şimdi
bu konuşmada buradan Neyi gördük bu
haritalarda
Dünya aynı dünya coğrafya
Ya Dünya aynı dünya fakat şu dünyadaki
büyü dünyadaki büyüklükler
aynı bakışımız farklılaşmış yarın bir
gün başka türlü de bakışımız
farklılaşacak bunlar hazır olmamız lazım
Hiçbir şey statik değil baştaki soru
vardı ya on bin yıl sonra Arkeologlar ne
bulacak Ankara'da
tahminde bulunmak isteyen var mı
buyurun
efendim
dinozor bulmayacaklar Belki de bulurlar
ama ne bulacaklar biliyor musunuz
Mesela bu büyük binaları bulmayacaklar
çünkü
biliyorsunuz ki betonun çeliği değil mi
asfaltın bir ömrü var çürüme ömrü var
yok olup gidecekler bunlar ya Yine neyi
bulacaklar biliyor musunuz
mermerlerini bulacaklar Çünkü içindeki
Beton Yapı çökmüş olacak mermerlerini
bulacaklar Anıtkabir aynı şekilde betonu
çökmüş olacak mermerlerini bulacaklar ve
bizim bugün konuştuğumuz lisanı böyle
bir şey yaparlarsa
nasıl çözecekler biliyor musunuz
Hadi bir tahminde
Anıtkabir'de Atatürk'ün gençliğe hitabı
yazılı ya
taşak kazılı bakın taş ve kazılı yazı
yok mürekkep yok
asfalt Yok bir şey yok
oradan çözerler Biz bugün hangi lisan
nasıl bir lisan konuşuyoruz
iz bırakmaktan mı Söz ediyorsunuz iz
bırakmak o
hala taşağa bağımlı bir uygarlığıyız
yani Kendimizi çok da büyükmeyelim böyle
bir karpuzun üstündeki toz zerresi gibi
yani
tamam mı Evet daha iyi bir hayat için
çalışıyoruz
işi daha özgürlükçü bir hayat için
ama hani bir arpa boyu geldiğimiz yolda
budur
beni sabırla dinlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim